welcome back to the David Pakman show for
today's plastic interview.
We're going back to when I spoke to high 11
back in 2014
scene and he told us about the religious gay
conversion therapy that he sang.
Experienced isn't even right, really was sort
of tortured through and suffered through.
And this is relevant for a couple of reasons.
Number one, gay conversion therapy for children
to be banned and more and more states.
And that's a good thing.
We also have a vice president currently in
Mike Pence who although he never actually
stated he supports the use of, you know, electroshock
for gay conversion or anything of the sort.
He did previously say that he would be okay
with federal funding to treat people that
want to change their sexual behavior, which
is very often coded language that the religious
right likes to use, talking about behavior
rather than sexual orientation as if these
are merely issues of choice.
So in that context, we'll go back to my interview
from a few years ago with high 11, the topic
of course, gay conversion therapy.
I'm joined today by Chaim 11, who has been
actively campaigning against so called conversion
therapy for years and writing about the subject
and hi, I'm, your story is so interesting
and I want to kind of start at the beginning.
You grew up as an orthodox Jew in Crown Heights,
Brooklyn, not very far from where I live or
from where our studio is.
In fact, uh, talk a little bit about your
background.
Did you always know that, that you were gay?
Did you always identify as a gay man?
Hi David.
Good afternoon.
Um, first of all, thank you for having me.
And um, that was pretty accurately described.
And, uh, so I mean that your question has
a kind of a couple of answers in the sense
that, uh, during my childhood I had this confusion
because I was sexually abused by a relative
for, for quite a number of years.
And for many years afterward, I believed that
this abuse that, uh, my, my cousin had inflicted
upon me had actually been the cause of my
sexual orientation.
Now, granted, I grew up in a very devout orthodox
community in the sense that, uh, in our schooling
system, we had no reading, no writing, no
spelling, no math, no science, no history,
no formal English, secular subjects, Strictly
Bible studies from nine to five every day
including Sunday.
So I didn't really know much about science
or about the world.
I knew that there was like the gay community
out there in the village that, you know, that
was whatever and not something that I was
connected to, but I was inside.
I was deeply troubled because I knew that
I was attracted to people of the same gender
and I, you know, and I kind of like just kept
pushing it away with the hope that, well,
you know, maybe if I study enough or if I
pray enough, uh, it will, it will just go
away or, you know, something like that.
And I was really hurt and that, uh, again,
because I have no outside, no knowledge about
this, I was certain that if I could overcome
my sexual abuse from my childhood, then somehow
I could change, you know, my, my attractions
and that's kind of where Jonah came in because
they were, there are the first ones to take
that idea and to uh, kind of magnify it times
10 and say yes of the reason you're, you're
gay is because of your sexual abuse.
It's also because you had a distant father
and a, and an overbearing mother and bottom
line, you know, they said we could change
you.
So that was all I needed to hear to start
right when I turned 18 I was,
yeah.
So let's tell for our audience who isn't familiar,
Jonah is Jews offering new alternatives to
homosexuality and hi, I'm talk a little bit
about when a rabbi actually told you that
there's a group that specializes in this,
whatever it was that, that he meant by this.
Presumably of course the so called conversion
therapy.
So you started going to, I hesitate to even
use the term therapist, but talk about who
it is that you started to see and what those
sessions were like.
Well, there were, um, just kind of compounded
there was, um, I had, uh, uh, disclose to
this rabbi.
I mean, it wasn't, I didn't really keep it
much of a massive secret in the sense that
I never identified as gay, but people knew
that I was struggling or, you know, Oh, you
know, I guess the way things in this community
are like, oh yeah, you know, it's such a pity
he has problems.
But I, you know, I kind of confided in this
rabbi said, I don't know what to do.
Uh, and he told me about Joan.
I know I had seen their advertisements in
the Jewish press, which is a mainstream, pretty
ultra orthodox, right wing newspaper that,
that it's read by everyone, including my parents
every week.
So when he told me Jonah, like I had already
heard of them, but I never, you know, so like
I connected with them.
Uh, I spoke to first the director, Mr Arthur
Goldberg, who, um, who, when I met him, he
said, you know, you, you must sign up for
this program called journey into manhood,
which is run by one of their sister organizations
called people can change.
Uh, he said, that's the first step that you
have to do and we also recommend, you know,
we, and then after you do that weekend, um,
you know, we could start helping you out here.
And this was just around the time that I was
turning 18, so I turned 18 on May 13th.
And then on June 1st I was headed to Pennsylvania
to a journey into manhood weekend with a bunch
of other men.
Um, you know, and it was kind of like a very
controlled environment where I was frightened.
I had no idea what to expect.
And a lot of very weird and disturbing things
happen on those weekends that I've spoken
about.
A number of them both, uh, you know, in writing
and my articles.
I've also, I've also testified to them, and
I can tell you this, uh, definitely, you know,
in hindsight, I look back and I say, you know,
something was so wrong in that, uh, it was
the first time that I had been interacting
with other gay people, but it was also the
first time that I had been interacting with
other people who weren't literally just like
me from the crown heights community, meaning
there were other Jews there.
But I had never even talked to other Jewish
people, even though they were technically
orthodox Jews.
They weren't from our sect.
Um, and one of the, one of the more disturbing
things that happened was that there was a
63 year old men, uh, a widower, an orthodox
woman to wear who was on this weekend and
a after the weekend he would call me nonstop.
He was calling me all the time.
Uh, he wanted to talk, you know, and he was
leaving me all these voicemails.
I kept ducking his calls.
And the last time I saw him, which was in
a group session by Jonah at Jonah's headquarters
and Jay in Jersey City during this group meeting,
he admitted to molesting three of his students,
two or three, I'm not sure the exact number
of his students in the, in the religious school
where he came from.
Uh, this never left the room and there were
10 people in the room and now putting it all
together, uh, I'm a survivor of sexual abuse.
Uh, now it's become very clear that Jonah,
Jonah, and these other groups state street,
so they treat gay people like pedophiles.
They were treating pedophiles.
I mean, I have a friend whose father was an
abuser and before he, uh, before his mom reported
him, uh, he was told by the directors of Jonah,
don't report your husband to us.
Don't, don't report your husband's in the
police.
Send them to us and we'll treat him and he'll
be safe and he'll be safe to be around your
other children.
And that for me personally, aside from the
fraud aspect of that, like this is like tried
to pick something that's not broken in a lot
of very dangerous ways.
Uh, the, the irresponsibility to put admitted
pedophiles, alder, you know, without in, in
contact with 18 year old kids.
Uh, you know, even though an 18 year old is
considered an adult, it's still so it's so
reckless.
Well, sure.
And of course the, I mean, the premise that
both require the same type of treatment is
obviously patently absurd.
So, hey, we, we don't have an unlimited amount
of time.
So there's a few other things I want to touch
on.
What were the credentials of these so called
therapists that you were assigned to, to work
with?
Well, they, they didn't actually didn't have
credentials.
They call themselves life coach, coaches,
life coaches.
Now, I had been seeing a female therapist
here in Brooklyn and when I started attending
Jonah, Arthur Goldberg told me it would be
better for me to see a male therapist and
he recommended their life coach who works
out of their office, Mr. Allen Downing.
So talk about, let's talk about that because
I think that that's just to, you know, it
really epitomizes what it is that's going
on here.
Talk about this last meeting that you had,
which you've spoken about and written about
with the layers of clothing.
Right.
So I had been seeing Mr Downing a kind of
sporadically, uh, for about a year and a half,
uh, you know, between monetary concerns and,
uh, just, you know, this, this and this hard.
I was like, like in and felt like I was an
exile cause I wasn't changing get, I was doing
all these things to change.
And I came to Downing's office and he, you
know, he started the session by getting me
to, uh, to talk about now.
But before I, before I do that, if you don't
mind, I'm just going to step back and say
that, you know, part of the one, a part of
these, the theories behind these things are,
you know, you have a broken masculine image,
right?
Or your, your masculinity needs to be repaired.
And so he got, he said, well, I want you to
create a few messages that you feel to be
true about, about, you know, about yourself,
negative messages.
Uh, and as we created them, he said, okay,
now I want you to say them out loud, instructing
me to stand in front of a mirror.
And he said with, you know, say one message
and take off a layer of clothing.
Now, immediately I had known, uh, which direction
the session was headed.
And then I told him, I turned to him and I
said, you know, I'm really not comfortable
doing this.
Um, this, uh, Mr Downing himself admits to
having what he calls same sex attraction,
like otherwise known as gay.
And, um, he, you know, and I was like, I'm
not, I'm not comfortable taking my clothes
off in front of a man who like three times
my age locked or in front of a mirror, especially
given the fact that he, yeah, I just, it was,
it was very uncomfortable, but I told him
no.
Uh, his, no, you know, my note to him was
not respected in the sense that she turned
it back around on me and said, well, why are
you afraid?
What are you afraid of?
You know, if you don't do this, then you're
not going to be completing the work.
And that's, that's the other trap that they
make, which is, oh, you didn't change because
you didn't work hard enough.
Right.
It seems that the entire thing is very carefully
crafted first.
Make it seem like you're an outlier.
There's something we have to fix.
And then if there's any resistance whatsoever
to the so called treatment that's prescribed,
you're then blamed for being part of the problem
or at least of not fixing the problem that
they've indicated exists.
Right, exactly.
And, and you know, it essentially is, it ended
in, my clothes were completely off.
I was completely naked in front of him and
he instructed me to touch my private parts
as a, as a, a indication or symbol or something
that will, uh, that would, that would indicate
me taking back my masculinity.
It's kind of similar to what Michael Ferguson
said in the, when we announced the new lawsuit,
which was had to do with the orange isn't
the balls.
Um, you know, it's all, it's all kind of these
like ridiculous exercises that are supposed
to represent something bigger.
Um, but you know, again, as a survivor of,
you know, four years of sexual abuse by my
first cousin who was six years older than
me, I've been spending, I've spent the last
10 years of my life transitioning from victim
to survivor.
And this was a real setback in a way because,
um, I, I tried to exert my power and say,
no, like, I don't want to do this.
This is not right.
Right.
But it really wasn't respected.
And I can say with certainty, the most offensive
part to all of this is that we've been, uh,
we've been in depositions over the last few
months and repeatedly I've been asked to equate
that session with, you know, sexual abuse
of my childhood, which one was worse?
Which one was more traumatizing to you?
And like, that's just ridiculous.
But that's, that's, you know, it's not, it
doesn't seem that they're denying that this
happens.
They're just defending it.
Absolutely.
Well, how do you listen to it?
There's so much more we could talk about.
Unfortunately.
We are at a time, we're going to be following
the lawsuit.
We didn't get into the details, but as you
mentioned, there is a lawsuit, so we will
follow it and we'll definitely have you back
on.
I can't thank you enough for being here and
sharing your story.
Thank you, David.
Thank you.